Please join me in what
calling Victoria Tucker.
Thank you very much and thank you
so much for everyone for coming.
Thanks for inviting me. It's a
real pleasure to be here. Um,
I'm Victoria Tech.
I,
I'm an editor at wired UK and
I've also just written this book,
digital etiquette, which is out this
week. Uh, before I go any further,
I just wanted to make a quick confession,
which is that this is the very first
talk I've given about this book.
And in fact it's pretty much the first
dog I've ever given about anything.
So you guys are my Guinea pigs and if
my knees look like they're shaking,
it's probably because they
are. Um, but anyway, yeah. Oh,
also it is the first
PowerPoint presentation I've
made since like high school.
Um, so I haven't used any clip art, but I,
I might have got a little bit
carried away with the animations.
It touch a keynote. Do you know, it didn't
even exist when I was at high school,
I think. Anyway. Um, so what
is digital etiquette? Um,
well the idea behind this book was
basically a fun modern take on the
traditional etiquette guide
for digital communications.
And I think a lot of people when they
think about this term etiquette, uh,
it sounds very old fashioned
and kind of stuffy,
but actually I think
it's super importance.
It is the social glue that makes it
possible to communicate with each other
without accidentally offending someone.
And we all kind of do it where the or not.
And I think it's especially important
online and in digital communications for
several reasons.
Firstly,
because most digital
communications are text based,
that means you're very limited in terms
of the tools that you have to get your
point across.
You've probably all had that situation
where you meet someone only over email
and you kind of get the impression that
they're very terse and very brusque and
kind of rude because their
emails are always really short.
But then you meet them in person and
that absolutely lovely and really nice.
So I think for that reason digital
communications can be full of a particular
pitfalls when it comes to you at a cat.
Also that obviously rarely,
truly private. Even if you think
you're just talking to one person, a,
your conversation could easily be shared
more widely and they leave a digital
trail.
So that angry email you send it three
in the morning is going to be in someone
else's inbox forever.
Once you've sent it.
Okay.
Say this is a saying you've
probably heard on the Internet,
no one knows you're a dog.
Yeah.
But that's no excuse for poor manners.
Now the book covers
for different chapters,
each of which is dedicated to a different
sphere of modern life. So there's uh,
the workplace romance,
which is obviously a lot of online dating,
friendship and community,
which is social media.
It would be impossible for me to attempt
to cover all of those here today.
Um, and given that this is for
most of you, your place of work,
I thought we'd focus on the workplace
and specifically on how to do email.
Um,
now I do realize the absolute conceit
of me coming into Google and trying to
tell you how to do email.
But the last I checked,
you don't have a chief ethercat
officer. So you know, maybe I can, uh,
bring up one or two points
that are of use. Um,
and actually just to see
what I'm dealing with.
Let's start with a quick question.
Um, let's talk about email sign offs.
I want you to think about
your default email sign off.
The one you use 90% of the time you type
it without even thinking who uses best
wishes.
So whenever that anyone use best or all
the best kind of variations on a theme,
quite a few. Great.
Who uses anything else?
Okay. It's worse than I thought
because you guys are wrong,
but we'll get to email sign offs and
the details of actually writing an email
later on.
Um,
first I want to step back a bit and just
think about the bigger picture of email
etiquette.
My driving philosophy
behind email etiquette, uh,
comes from one pretty universal truth.
Everyone hates email. Again, maybe
not the best place to be saying that.
I'm sure there's a few of you out
there. Um, now don't get me wrong.
Email is a fantastic innovation.
There's a reason we all
use it and we still use it
decades after it was invented.
Uh,
it lets us communicate with people on
the other side of the worlds in different
time zones and it's really actually
reshaped workplace culture.
I don't think it would be possible to
work remotely if we didn't have email.
So is you know, a really great thing and
it is often very convenient. However,
it's also stressful time consuming,
annoying and it often feels like it
no longer just helps us to do work.
It actually is work. You don't see many
job ads were in the listing. They put,
you know, the skills required
being really good at email.
And yet I've spent whole days in my inbox
just writing and responding to emails.
I don't think anyone really wakes up
full of a sense of joy or the number of
unread, unread messages
they've got in their inbox in
the morning, in the morning.
I think you probably feel more
of a sense of dread and he's,
I hope I'm not the only one.
In fact,
I know I'm not the only one cause there
have been studies that have shown this.
Um, one of my favorites is
actually a really small study,
but I really liked it because
they actually put heart
rate monitors on a bunch
of office workers and they made them
go about their daily business and they
tracked their email usage and they found
that the more people spent on email in
a given day, the more stressed they
were and the less productive they felt.
I think we can probably
all relate to that.
So based on that, given that email
is terrible and everyone hates it,
the main principle of good email Atget
if do reduce it as much as possible.
Every time you send an email you are
asking to take up someone else's time and
mental energy.
So obviously that means you should only
send emails when you actually need to,
but when you do,
you also want to make sure that you're
making it as easy as possible for your
recipient to deal with.
You want to make sure you're including
all the information the first time round.
So you're sending one email and not 10
and you just want to make it very clear.
You want to be concise and precise,
take up as little time as possible and
make it as easy to deal with as possible.
And often the best email is
actually the one you don't send.
So that said, sometimes
you do need to email.
Sometimes it is a good thing an
email has become for many workplaces,
the default means of communicating
certainly an office space, workplaces, uh,
that is changing a bit at least
for internal communications. Um,
I know a lot of officers use
instant messaging tools like slack.
I'm sure you guys probably use Google
hangouts. I'm getting lots of nods. Yep.
Um, but certainly for external
communications and still a lot of internal
communications,
email is king.
It's the thing you kind of
just automatic you go to first,
but maybe you shouldn't always because
the very same things that make email
really good for some things
make it really bad for others.
So what is email good for?
It's good for distributing information,
especially if you need to send a
message to lots of people at once,
especially if it's quite a long message.
Maybe you need to attach documents.
Perfect, simple back and forth
at Kiva. That was simple.
But if you want to have a quick question,
answer, question, answer with someone,
it can work. Um, you know,
if you have too many people on a thread
or the threat goes on for too long,
it can very quickly get
confused. Um, so simple is key.
Starting a paper trail.
Um,
I think this is particularly important
if you're working on a project that you
know is going to take
quite a lot of a long time.
One really good thing about email
is it's really easy to search.
It's not so easy to search back old
instant messages and things like that.
Um, but you can find an old email
from days ago, weeks ago, months ago,
even years ago, very easily.
So great. But more importantly,
what is email not good for?
It's good for immediate responses.
This is actually a bit of a controversial
one because I think certainly today a
lot of people expect immediate responses
or near immediate responses from email.
But going back to the whole nature
of email and the first base,
the whole point of it is that
it is asynchronous. Okay.
So you can send an email at one time and
your recipient can pick it up whenever
they like,
you could send it one evening,
they pick it up the
following following morning.
That is one of the major benefits of email
we'll get onto how fast you should be
expected to respond soon.
Uh,
but I do hold that if you're looking
for a really immediate response,
you shouldn't be relying on email,
discussion and debate.
I can't emphasize enough that email
is not a discursive medium. Um,
I know the one thing people hate more
than email is meetings, but if your heart,
if you have some kind of problem,
especially if you need to work as a group
to come together to create a solution
or come to some conclusion,
email is just way too open for
miscommunications in that situation.
So it might be better
just to speak in person
and nuance I mentioned at
the beginning of the talk,
the thing about digital communications
is it can be very hard to get your
meaning across and especially to get any
kind of sense of your emotional meaning
across. Um, so if it's a
situation that's a bit sensitive,
you probably want to be choosing a format
where you can use those nonverbal cues
like tone of voice, like facial
expression, body language, uh,
to make sure that you're
not misunderstood.
And that's not only to make sure that
your coming across the way you want to,
but also so you can pick up on those
cues from the other person and you're
dealing with and maybe kind of tune your,
your response along the way.
So you've decided that you do need to
send an email and the email is definitely
the best medium I key thing around
email and to get his timing,
um,
when to send an email.
So obviously I mentioned that email is
asynchronous and that you shouldn't be
expecting an immediate response.
Expectations have changed hugely over
the past decade because of smartphones.
Um, you know, it's pretty obvious point.
It used to be that when you
left the office at night,
you leave your computer and you wouldn't
be expected to check your email until
the next morning. In fact, you probably
couldn't, you couldn't even be tempted to,
uh,
because you had an immune cell doing say,
now we've come to expect everyone to carry
these mini computers in their pockets.
I mean, it's better than to
be available 24, seven. Um,
and this has really blurred the lines
between work life and personal life to the
extent actually that France recently
brought in a new law called the Dwight
[inaudible], uh, which is
like the right to disconnect.
And it essentially in shrines in look at
your right to ignore your boss's email
on the weekend,
um,
because they recognize that work life
was just impinging on personal and family
life. Um, so that workers
could never switch off.
And I think if you wouldn't expect someone
to be in the office that late working,
you shouldn't expect them to be checking
that email, that late working. Okay.
It takes just as much effort to do so.
Uh,
so I really think that you should stick
to work hours or near abouts I here,
none of us are perfect. Maybe
an hour or so either side. Um,
but try and stick to work hours and try
if you want to be extra good and stick
to your recipient's work hours, especially
if they're in a different time zone.
Now you might say, you know, that's
great. I totally respect my colleagues,
right? To have a personal life and to
not check that emails in the evening.
But I the super conscientious worker,
I really liked sending emails
late at night, you know,
I actually enjoy it and that way
I'm not keeping anyone waiting.
They've got their answer as soon as they
want it and I feel good about myself,
I can take it off my to
do list and I'm done.
The problem is that goes back to
the original paradox of email.
There you are enjoying the convenience
of being able to send it at anytime but
you're putting the stress on your
recipient because even if you don't expect
them to respond immediately,
they're going to feel that
unread email guild they are.
And they're going to be unsure about
whether they're supposed to be replying
right then or not.
So the onus is on you as a
sender to set a reasonable norm.
And if you really want to be
answering your emails late,
you can also use the delay send function
so you can just schedule it to email
the next morning,
which makes us to how fast
do you respond to an email?
And this is obviously the first thing
that comes up whenever I bring up the idea
of email etiquette with people.
And what's really funny is that people
have completely different views on this.
And I think this is one of the main
things that contributes to email stress in
the first place,
is that we don't have an agreed consensus
on what was supposed to be doing.
So we're all just kind of
scrambling around trying to
please everyone and no one
knows what they're supposed to be doing.
Um,
now it's easy to say good educate is to
respond to an email as fast as possible.
Usually if someone's emailed you, asking
you something, they want a fast response.
Um, but it obviously is
just so context dependent.
It could be something really simple
that you can respond to right away or it
could be something that actually requires
quite a lot of work. Um, and that,
you know, you might not be expected
to respond for several days.
So it's a bit of a cop out answer here.
There is no one size fits all,
but there is a sort of
workaround achieved ask them.
Um,
so yeah,
I think a lot of people assume that
etiquette has to be this sort of unspoken
thing. I kind of secret code that
everyone else, but you knows. Um, but I,
I'm very much pro being transparent
and being very practical.
So if you receive a message and you don't
know what you're expected to do with
it, just send a quick line back. Say Hi,
is it okay if I get back to
him this by Friday? Or Hey,
this is going to take me some
work. When do you need it? By easy,
I'm faster flies are actually
not always the best etiquettes.
Um,
I think a good example of
this is if you're on an email,
which has been sent to a group of people,
say it's been sent to your whole team.
I used to be this person who at the
beginning of my career I really wanted to
show how keen I was and how
ready to work and ego was to, uh,
to get involved with everything.
So if our boss would send an email
to the whole team asking for input,
I'd immediately jumped in with my
2 cents and I thought, you know,
I was just showing how great I was,
what a good worker actually.
Obviously I was just being super annoying.
Um,
I think in that situation it's
much better etiquette to sit back,
wait awhile, see what other people
say, see if your input is even needed.
And if it is when you do respond to if
they've got all the information that you
need. And I think not only
is that good etiquette,
but there's actually a lot of power in
being able to do that and give kind of
one very well informed response.
All right,
how to write an email.
I promise I'm not patching eyes on you
guys is I honestly think this is really
hard. I get it wrong all the
time. Um, I think everyone,
it gets it wrong a lot.
Um,
everything of course goes back to thinking
about your recipient and reducing the
burden of email on them.
So precision and concentrate
in or both your friends. Um,
and this is a quote from Merlin Mann.
Does anyone know who he is?
He's a speaker,
a podcaster and a writer and
he coined the term inbox zero.
Have you guys heard of inbox zero.
Okay. Quite a lot of recognition there.
That's good.
Um,
I won't go through exactly what
inbox zero is in this presentation,
but it's basically a way to stay on top
of your email so that you don't drown in
unread messages. Um, I'm, I'm a
huge kind of devoted to inbox zero.
Anyway,
Merlin was kind enough to speak to me
for this book and this is one thing he
said, which I think really, um,
really makes a good point when
you're going to write an email.
So he says assume that everyone you're
communicating with is smarter than you
and cares more than you and is busier
than you. Sounds kind of obvious,
but I feel like we all almost
automatically do the opposite.
You sort of think this is really
important. Why haven't they responded? Um,
and obviously it's better to just consider
the other person if they're writing
an email.
Let's start from the top subject lines.
I'm pretty simple.
Keep it descriptive.
Again, you're trying to make your
email super easy to deal with.
So you need something that helps people
categorize it and so they can see at a
glance what it's going to be about and
what probably the adaptations on them
we're going to be. I've got a few
examples of how not to do it. Um,
and I've used it a scenario that I think
everyone who works in an office will be
familiar with. So here's our email. Hi
all feeds. Can everyone remember that?
If you use a mug from the kitchen,
it is your responsibility to wash it up.
Has anyone ever received an
email like that? Yeah. Now,
you'll notice in this email,
there is no subject line.
The subject line has been left blank.
Don't do that. It's super annoying.
When you go to check your email,
you just see who's who it's sent from and
there's no subject and you immediately
assume the worst, right? You're
like, Oh God, I'm in trouble. I mean,
you could argue you're in trouble
there, but yeah. Um, so don't do that.
Yeah.
Don't put the whole message in the
subject line. I've seen people do this.
I often see, actually I'm quite senior
people have a habit of doing this.
And again, it's super annoying, especially
if you check your email on mobile,
you only get the first
few words and it's like,
what am I supposed to be doing with that?
The clickbait headline.
Uh, yeah, I've seen quite
a few of these in my time,
usually from pos trying to
get my attention. Um, yeah,
obviously it's dismissed eating.
It's not very useful and you probably
think you're being really funny,
but you're not.
Yeah.
Okay. Oh, Jen. Kitchen mess. Um,
yeah. So it's okay to play the
urgent card every now and then.
If it truly is urgent, if
you need a fast response, uh,
but every time you play that card,
you are devaluing it.
I don't think many people would
consider this an actual emergency. Uh,
so be very judicious with urgents and
going back to the whole point of email
etiquette as well.
If it wasn't at least a bit important,
you probably shouldn't be sending the
email in the first place. Uh, so yeah,
so this is what I've gone
for. Kitchen mass. Um, yeah,
it's totally boring,
completely bland and therefore absolutely
perfect for professional situation.
Um, so that's subject mines.
How to start the email.
This is pretty easy,
so I won't spend too long on that.
Um, you don't need to
greet someone every time,
especially if you have back and
forth thread. Um, so, you know,
obviously you might first day high,
uh,
but it's like if you're
having a conversation,
if you're having a quick back and forth
email thread, you wouldn't say like, hi,
how are you? Hi, I'm
great. Hi. That's good. Hi.
And what about yourself?
Hi. Yeah, good too. Thanks.
You just wouldn't do it and you
don't have to do on email either one,
established the back and forth
conversation, fine to omit it. Um,
I usually just as like a rule of thumb,
if a day has passed so you slept on it,
I'll then kind of do a greeting again.
Um,
dare someone is not usually necessary
unless the email is taking the place of
sort of a formal letter.
So fits a cover letter for
a job application or an
official invitation of some
sort.
Then you might want to use dare it's 2019.
You can probably use someone's first name.
The exception I make is if they have
a title that is not ms Mr Ms. Mrs. Um,
so if it's something like doctor,
professor, Lord Lady Madam Sir,
I would use the title the first time
around just because some people are quite
picky about that.
Um,
and then when they respond they'll
probably sign off with their first name.
You're on a first name basis, that's
fine, but they're not usually necessary.
Hi.
It's probably fine
striking the right tone.
Um,
I mentioned kind of several times
already that this is truly difficult.
Um,
email is terrible for communicating
emotion for this reason.
I actually am totally pro things like
Emoji using lots of exclamation marks.
Um, whatever it is that helps you
to express your emotional meaning,
um, and get your view across more
clearly I think is totally fine.
Obviously that's going to be a bit
dependent on where you work and what your
position is. Uh, if
you're sort of a lawyer,
smiley faces might not be
appropriate. Um, but you know,
in the media world usually totally fine.
Um,
so anything that you can do to
kind of be clear is a good thing.
Um,
and again,
striking the right tone is going
to depend a lot on context. Um,
so you do have to kind of make
a lot of judgment calls there,
but there are a few stereotypical ways
that people email that I've observed and
I think that everyone in this room will
probably be able to recognize at least
one person they know who does
each of these, the boss emailer.
Um, so this is the concept
of emailing like a CEO, uh,
and Katie and a topless, uh,
American digital journalist.
She wrote this great piece about
emailing like a CEO. What is that?
It's when you respond right away,
but just as like one or two words,
like just okay.
Um,
and she noticed that her boss did
this and it's also kind of, um,
a thing that a lot of tech
CEOs are quite well known for.
You probably know Amazon's Jeff Bezos,
he's renowned for forwarding emails from
customers to Amazon staff with not even
a word, just a character, a question
mark. Can you imagine receiving that?
The horror? Um, so yeah,
emailing like a CEO,
I spoke to Katie about this cause she
kind of did an experiment where she tried
it for a week. Um, and she said
it was actually really great.
It made her feel so much more productive.
She really stayed on top of
things and she told me, you know,
she never realized before
how much email hung over her,
like a little black cloud.
So it definitely has its advantages.
Um,
you know,
it helps you be able to kind of maintain
your inbox zero if that's what you're
working towards.
But you have to exercise caution because
there's a very fine line between being
concise and being brusque and
being brusque and being rude.
So it's a really difficult one to judge.
Um,
and there's a certain thing to be said
about who is able to do this is called
emailing like a CEO and it tends
to be people in senior positions.
So if you do it and when you get
higher up the pecking order, you know,
maybe you have a bit more licensed
to actually just be a bit rude. Uh,
so it really depends kind of where you
are on whether you can get away with it
or not. And if you work in something
like customer relations or HR,
there's a certain expectation on you
that you have to be a bit sort of more
gentle in your email tone.
So that's the boss emailer,
the corporate jog on Waffler. Um, this is
almost the opposite of the boss emailer,
yet they have the same aspirations,
right?
So this is someone who sort of sees
every email as an official missive to be
carefully crafted. Um, yeah,
they're probably read a lot of business
books and there were always into the
latest sort of trends in thought he to
ship and they try and use that in their
writing. So they end up with
things like this sort of stuff.
Uh,
you can probably tell from this,
I've never actually worked in
a really corporate environment,
but my partner who's a
management consultant tells me
that it's not that far off.
Um, so yeah, you've probably all
received something like that,
which means obviously
absolutely nothing at all.
Definitely want to avoid
third type of emailer.
I couldn't think of a name for this one.
Um,
that's the best thing I could
come up with to describe it. Um,
and I now realize, obviously this,
that headline right next to me,
and probably everyone could just take
a picture and put it on social media,
but that would obviously be
terrible digital etiquette.
So I'm sure you wouldn't
do that. Um, but yeah,
so this I think is actually a really,
it's a,
it's a big phenomenon and I think I have
definitely been guilty of this in the
past. I'm sure it will be guilty
of doing it in the future.
I think it's actually a very British
thing where especially if you get a little
bit annoyed or a little bit
worked up instead of being rude,
you kind of go overly formal in a
way that looks extensively plight.
But is that she's just
super passive aggressive.
So instead of saying something like,
um, kind of get back to me soon,
perfectly normal and acceptable,
you'd say something like,
I would be much obliged if you could
kindly respond to this message or earliest
convenience.
Yeah.
Has anyone ever done that?
Yeah, we've got that. A few,
a few people are confessing that one.
So that's another one to be
aware of. Um, before we move on,
a few common email translations,
I find it really funny that we will have
these set phrases that we seem to use
an email and we wouldn't consider
saying them anywhere else.
It's just that kind of email language.
And I think it's especially funny
when I see the GML suggested automated
responses because they're always so spot
on because we all already just email
like robots.
Um,
so we'll just go through a few
apologies for the delayed response.
Um,
yeah,
it's just the law that you have to start
messages with that I think I've tried
not to my hands just do it.
Yeah.
Hope you're well. Um, yeah.
There's really no needs to ask after
someone's health unless you have a reason
to be concerned.
We all know this is an authentic
and you don't actually want to know.
Okay.
Not sure if you saw my last message.
Yeah,
you definitely saw my last message.
I'm obviously what we,
what you mean with that is that hey,
why haven't you responded
just following up? Um, yeah,
we're always just following
up for me. Um, no,
you're never just following up, you
know, if you're just following up,
why you send sending me email and just
ask the question that you need to be
answered.
Does that make sense?
Um,
of course it makes sense.
You wouldn't be sending the email if
it didn't make sense. If you would,
you need to go back and start redrafting.
Thanks in advance. Um, yeah,
I'm going to talk about thanks in advance
a bit more, uh, in the next slide.
Um, but yeah, obviously it's the, again,
going back to that kind of
passive aggressive thing,
it doesn't really mean what it
seems to you on the surface.
So facts of what I asked at the
beginning and email sign offs.
Um,
these are the ones I'll accept basically
best wishes or any variations on them.
Why do I think there a
good email fine off, um,
that inoffensive the formal enough
without being overly formal.
Um,
the totally boring again,
which makes them just perfect for at
least 90% of workplace communication.
So you're not going to offend anyone
with a best wishes. What do I not like
that? Has anyone seen that one?
I've seen that in the wild. I, yeah,
you've obviously taken a
perfectly good sign off,
best wishes and turned it into an
utter abomination kind of Gods.
A lot of people use this one.
Does anyone use kind regards?
You're going to admit to it. We've got one
over there. Yeah, yeah, we've got a few,
you know, it's fine. It's probably okay.
I just think it's a bit overly formal
for most situations in the modern
workplace. And I think when you do
that and you go a bit too formal,
it can come off as standoffish and a bit
stuffy and maybe it's maybe not giving
the impression that
you quite want to give.
Okay.
Cheers. I used it as all the time with
my colleagues and I'm also friends with,
and I think that's fine
in an informal situation,
but as your default sign off
is probably not appropriate.
It's a little bit too informal.
So it's just striking that balance.
Ah, thanks in advance again, this is,
and I've saved the west the last
because I really hate thanks in advance.
Why do I hate it so much?
Because it's,
sorry, let me gather my thoughts. Okay.
Does, I mean it's just so presumptuous,
um,
because that's not how gratitude works.
You don't think someone before
they've agreed to do something right.
It's just saying like,
Oh yeah,
you realize that you have no
way of getting out of this. Um,
say I hate thanks in advance.
Um,
definitely want to avoid thanks
someone after doing something.
Oh, right. So email sign offs.
Um, great. So we've gone through pretty
much all the main parts of doing an email.
So you're ready to send
it. One last thing, um,
and actually I think this is,
if you take one thing from this talk,
let it be this. Let's all
agree on how to use SI. Si.
I'm serious.
So when should you cc on an email?
So obviously this is when you're
sending an email to all recipients.
It's a very simple rule.
There is a strict rule for this.
The two field is for primary recipients
of an email who are expected to respond.
The CC field is for people who need to
see the email for reference only and who
are not expected to respond.
Now, I didn't come up for this.
I'm not reinventing the wheel.
Do you know the um,
the big old fashioned etiquette guide,
the brats, the edition I have at home,
it's got two pages in the whole thing
dedicated to the whole of digital
communications. That's about the same
as it has for how to address a bishop.
But even it's includes this cc rule.
That's how important it
is. Um, why is it useful?
You're just making very clear what your
expect expectations on your recipients.
Ah,
and so that is again,
reducing the burden of
email stress on the world.
Uh, if people are on CC, they
know they don't need to respond.
If they're in the to field,
they know they have to.
Obviously the problem here is that not
everyone may be aware of this rule.
So what you can do to help
kind of establish good
email hygiene is if you send
an email, you could just say, so you can
just put something like a to those on cc,
no need to respond.
This is just an Fyi.
And then you don't end up in that kind
of awkward situation where you've got
people who you just included as a kind
of courtesy responding and turning it
into this whole thread from hell.
Actually that's another point on CC.
Like when should you include people on cc?
Obviously the kind of top level
rule of reducing email, uh,
means you should only include
people when it's necessary. However,
people's feelings kind of
Trump that productivity.
I'm so good at ACAP means taking
peep other people into consideration.
So if you're, for example,
emailing a whole team of people,
you really need to include the mall.
You can't just include half of them,
even if not everyone is
on a need to know basis.
And so I call that tossing
a to CCC. It's like, ah,
I'm including you even though
I don't really care. Um,
but yeah, just so everyone,
no one feels left out. Um, cc,
however, it isn't always a courtesy.
Has anyone ever been in that position
where someone emails you to ask you to do
something or maybe even complain about
something you've done and they so
thoughtfully think to cc
your boss? Yeah, that's,
that's not a courtesy cc that
should be avoided at all costs.
It's very, it's not even passive
aggressive. It's just aggressive. Um,
and the thing is if you genuinely
need to complain about someone,
you should be going through
the correct channels, right?
You shouldn't be sort of doing the
snide like cc or superiors. Um,
it's, it's, it's like
blackmail. It's like saying,
if you don't respond to this
email how I want you to,
you're going to be in trouble.
So don't do that.
Now that is of course an
alternative to CC BCC a,
it stands for blind carbon copy,
as you will know. So if, um,
if you send an email to someone
and include someone on BCC,
your original recipient can't tell
that anyone else is privy to that
conversation.
That means it can be incredibly sneaky.
And for that reason, it's
usually very poor advocates. Um,
and dabettes actually covers this as well.
It says,
if you need to loop someone in on an
email conversation confidentially,
you should forward the email to
them with a note explaining why it's
confidential.
That way you don't get in one of those
awkward situations where someone doesn't
realize they were on BCC and
not cc, et Cetera, et cetera.
But the Rfu situations where BCC is
not only acceptable but very necessary,
okay
to protect people's identities. So if
you're emailing a whole group of people,
you don't want to reveal their names
and their email addresses to each other,
email it to yourself and put everyone
else on BCC. This is super important.
Sometimes it can even be a
legal requirement. In 2016,
there was a linden NHS
clinic, um, the accident,
he revealed the identity of hundreds of
people who do use an HIV clinic because
someone forgot to put them on BCC.
So they will all leave together. Uh,
they will obviously find lots for that.
Um,
hopefully you guys aren't doing
anything quite as sensitive as that,
but it's still useful to use.
So void of reply all apocalypse.
Do you all know what I mean? If I
say a reply or apocalypse? Yeah.
When someone sends an email usually to
like an office mailing list and they
think it's just for their department,
but it ends up being like the whole
office and also all the global offices and
someone replies back in,
they're like, the classic,
take me off this thread and then everyone
else does and you end up with this
huge pile up. Um, so BCC,
if you're emailing lots of people
and you want to avoid that,
it can be a useful tool because all the
people who are on BCC on not able to
reply all, they can only reply to the
person who actually sent the email.
Another example also
from the NHS actually,
which apparently has some work to do
on its email skills. Um, they had,
if you think,
you know,
reply or apocalypses that you've seen
have been that they had one also in 2016
at the effected the entirety of Nhs Mail
and it resulted and around 500 million
emails being sent because they were all
sent to every other person with an NF
test mail address. Um,
so yeah, it can be bad.
Okay.
To nobody saves someone else's inbox at,
this is a quite specific situation,
but it actually comes up all the time.
Um,
so this is when someone emails you and
a colleague with a request and you say,
Oh, you know what, actually I'm
better placed to deal with this. Uh,
no need for my colleague to be involved.
So what you should do is respond to them.
Move your colleague to bcc and say in
the email something to the effective,
Hey,
I'm best placed to deal with this,
moving Sally to bcc to save her inbox.
And that means that Sally,
well then no longer receive any more
emails on the thread. So you, you know,
it's the ultimate act of
email self sacrifice, right?
You're taking on that thread and saying
actually you didn't need be involved,
don't worry about it. So that's some
real, that's a really good thing to do.
Um,
okay,
we're coming to the end now cause I think
we've covered most of the major points.
Um, oh just as I was talking about a
reply or apocalypse and using the all all
office email address, I
thought I had to end. Um,
obviously if you've been paying attention,
you should be able to work out for now
that you should never really be using an
all office email address
unless you really have to.
The three circumstances
under which it is acceptable,
a genuine emergency,
unofficial announcement and free food.
Now one of those is a joke.
Can you tell which one?
Genuine emergency you shouldn't
be emailing in a fire. Um,
thank you very much
everyone for listening.
My Name's Victoria Tech digital ads to
get the book it's out this week. Um,
that's my Twitter handle. If you
want to tweet abuse at me later. Um,
and I think we're going
to have some questions.
Thank you very much.
Sorry for questions.
Please go to the microphone in the middle
of the room so we can all hear you. Um,
um, uh, yeah, while you're going
there. The first question about me,
um, you talked about, uh, business,
email of Worki mo mostly.
Um,
do you see any general difference
between a work email and uh,
and personal email?
Um,
I have to say I don't really know that
many people who emailed in their personal
lives that much anymore. Does
anyone here email for fun? A couple?
Um, yeah, obviously the
rules are very different. Um,
it all goes back to kind of that
context of how far we need to be.
If you're actually genuinely
friends with people,
you can be a lot more kind
of free any spoken. Um,
and you don't have to abide
by the rules so much. Um,
I think the really interesting thing about
email actually is that it can kind of
take the place of
several different things.
It used to be very much used
like a snail mail letter.
Now it's often used more
like a text message. Um,
and I think in your personal life you're
probably going to be doing more of the
latter. Yeah. Use laser were
majors would be my advice.
All right,
so
let's,
let's start with the assumption that all
of the people in the room now are able
to craft the perfect evening
now at the right times and like,
we're all going to be good.
But how do we actually deal with
receiving emails that are not appropriate?
I mean,
how do we actually respond to
the thanks in advance at night?
And how do we encourage people to
like follow the digital etiquette?
Preston?
Yeah.
Mean obviously it would be quite poor
etiquette if you went off at your
colleague for using thanks in advance.
Um,
so there's not much you can do on
that one except for kind of, you know,
silently enjoy the feeling of self
worth you get from doing it better. Um,
for email sent at nights.
I think workplaces on the whole should
establish kind of better codes of conduct
when it comes to email is so often this
thing that it's assumed that everyone
knows how to do it and
how to do it correctly.
And actually expectations just vary so
widely that that's clearly not the case.
So I think every workplace should have,
I kind of standard set of rules on when
you're supposed to be emailing a knots.
It's really funny isn't it?
Because we all seem to assume now that
we have smartphones and that we are
technically contactable most of the
time that we need to always be on call.
Like I'm a culture journalist.
There's not many emergencies where I'm
going to be the person that someone calls.
And yet even I'm like, Oh gosh, I've got
an email. I better check it just in case.
Um, I don't think that's
ever been super urgent. Um,
but it is hard to get out
of that mentality. So I do
think as send it, I send us,
you have to, the kind of onus to fix
that is on you if we receive, uh,
obviously, um, if it's
possible, just don't answer it.
I think people get different expectations
around different people based on your
behavior as well. If they know that
you're going to answer it 11:00 PM,
because you always do,
they're probably going to keep doing that.
Whereas if you establish that kind of
routine where actually I don't answer my
emails until,
okay,
eight 30 in the morning
or nine in the morning,
then they may end up respecting
that without you having
to actually say anything.
Okay.
Oh, hi. Thanks for the talk on the
subject of the email sign offs, uh,
one option which you didn't mention
is how about having no sign of a, all,
there's something I do sometimes and
take a picture plane to an existing
conversation or a
colleague I Novell faster.
Yeah. Um, I'd say that similar
to the greeting at the beginning,
if you're having a back and forth with
someone you don't need to sign off. Um,
and I often actually just sign off
with the Letter v the first and it says
letter of my name. Um, and
I think in that context,
that's fine. The first email you send,
I think you do need to sign off. Um,
again,
I'm see if it's a more sort of acting
more like a letter than a text message,
then you need sign off.
But I don't think there's anything
rude about having no sign off if you're
treating it like a back and forth
conversation. I think that's fine.
Hey, thanks for coming.
Thanks for coming. Um,
you talked about email and
professional environment.
I'm sure that in the book you also talk
about personal relationships as you said.
Can you,
can we hear your thoughts on what we
call the dictatorship of the blue tick?
You know, like when you send a message,
someone sees that you sold, I have sex,
you want someone's story on
Instagram and they're like,
I know that you've walked through
it and you didn't see anything.
And then there's like, oh, am
I supposed to do? Yeah, being
left on red is excruciating,
right?
When you can see someone's read your
whatsapp and they haven't bothered to
respond and you're like, but
you had time to check in. Um,
what do I think about that? I think
you shouldn't leave people on red. Um,
I think we've probably shouldn't
be so neurotic about it,
but I don't know how to fix
that. Um, I'm terrible for this.
I read so much into those
little boutiques. Um,
so I think if I relate
it back to inbox zero,
which I mentioned earlier,
part of the rules of inbox zero
is if you check your inbox,
if you check an email, you have to
have time to do something about it.
There's no point looking at it.
If you know you're not gonna be able to
do anything about it cause then you're
just going to have to read it twice and
you've kind of doubled the amount of
time spent on it.
I think it would be good to apply a
kind of similar idea to your whatsapp
messages if you're checking them,
you should have time to answer.
Um, and that way you don't end up
leaving people on red. And again,
it could be the same where, you know, if,
if it's someone kind of trying to organize
a dinner and asking you lots of dates
and you need to check your calendar,
you can just respond like, oh,
check this later.
Um,
but that way they at least know
that you've seen that message.
Because that's the thing about
the blue ticks is we used to,
you know,
before you had them,
someone could see your
message and not respond to it,
but you wouldn't be so bothered
about it because you just,
you could invent all these myths about
why they hadn't responded. Like, oh,
they haven't dead their phone. Oh, they're
probably really busy. Oh, you know,
maybe they died in a ditch. Um,
but when you see the blue ticks,
you know, they've actually seen it
and that's what's so irritating.
Do you acknowledge that most of us don't
use email for personal stuff anymore?
Do you think that it's entirely a good
thing? Or there's cases for example,
like planning a holiday or something.
Would a whatsapp group or an email
thread to be better for that?
That's an interesting question cause I
just tried to hop to plan a holiday with
my family over whatsapp and
like we all fell out. Um,
it was a disaster.
Would email have been better,
you know, for something like that
where it involves lots of discussion.
I think the best thing is
an actual conversation.
Obviously that isn't always possible.
I suppose the advantage of emails,
you can include more information,
you can put links to stuff
and things like that. Um,
yeah, I mean I just think, I don't even
know most of my friends email addresses.
Um,
so I just think it's not the kind of go
to communication for those more sort of
friendly situations these days.
Maybe it should be.
Maybe we should just try to revive it.
I think maybe everyone's so put off email
just from work email and it just being
so terrible. Um, that I'm,
I'm kind of loath to try to that
into my private life. Thanks.
Well transfer questions. Um, thanks.
Good Talk.
Um,
having sent email for decades,
I'm from a very nerdy,
um,
sort of area.
The majority of males I dealt with
were reply in line with the Chevron
invitation.
Moving the thread was he as a follow up,
oh my God,
look came up,
came along and the curse of flushed at
the top and sort of new generation of non
tech started just replying
top posting and a,
it's a different style of email arrived
and then you can't mix the two at all.
Google, I thought I'd given
up and the second sale.
But at Google it's surprising there's
a good 40%. Males are replying lines.
Lists like this is still
survived as a, as a thing. And I,
I just wanted to know what your,
your take on that was. You know,
should I just give up and I'm just
an old timer and I should just,
or is this really,
it can lead to quite a nice thread,
a very good easy way to
follow what's going on.
You're applying to
specific bits or discuss.
Yeah,
that's a really good point actually,
because that I think is when
things can go really wrong is when,
is when you mix the two.
Right?
And so the thread goes completely
out of control and it's kind of part
chronological and then it skipped
something and you're like, whoa. Um,
I'd say,
I think most people don't even think
about this and they rely on the technology
to do it for them. Um, I don't,
I'm not sure if I have a particular
preference for one or the other.
I think the problem is if you're mixing,
so as soon as the threat is
established in a certain way,
you should just follow suit.
That's probably the best
answer I have on that one.
Which do you prefer and line?
Yeah.
All right. Oh, we are at the end. Oh. So
once again, thank you very much, Victoria.
Thank you.